- Alright, well, good evening, everyone.
Thanks for joining us.
It's 5:30.
Actually, before I start, silent session.
So make sure you have your headphones on.
Can everybody hear me okay? Good? Awesome.
If it's a little too loud
or if you need to adjust the
volume, there's a little dial
so you can use it to adjust your volume.
But thanks for joining us.
It's 5:30, it's around
this time where we decide
between like happy hour or dinner,
but you squeezed in a
session which tells us,
and you picked this
session, which tells us
that lifecycle management at scale is
a topic that you're interested in.
So we appreciate you being here.
My name is Farzin Bagheri, I'm
a principal technical account
manager at AWS and I'm
joined here by my colleagues.
So I'll let them introduce
themselves real quick.
- Hi, I'm Andrew Riley. I'm
also a principal team at AWS.
- Hi, everyone. Gian Mario Deluigi here.
I'm from the ServiceNow family
and I cover the item products.
Super excited to be here with you all.
- Thank you.
Folks, they're gonna join me later
after when it's their turn,
but for now, you'll have me on the stage.
Today, together, the three of us,
will dive deep into lifecycle
management at scale.
By the end of the session, you'll see
that it's very much possible
to move away from managing
thousands of lifecycle emails,
improve your operational
practices by 90%, improve
your operational efficiency,
and reduce your cost of
operations significantly
by reducing your need to
use extended support of some
of our managed services.
We will get there by
first diving deep into
what lifecycle events are in the cloud.
I'll walk us through what are
the common lifecycle events
that we manage in AWS
and I'll also walk us
through the common challenges
that we've learned from some
of our largest customers
and engaging with them.
Andrew later will do a
walkthrough of what AWS Health is.
We'll dive deeper into that
and how it fits into the
lifecycle management ecosystem,
how that actually is a very
critical component in enabling
customers to manage lifecycle at scale.
Then he will also run through some
practical implementation
of AWS Health by some
of our largest customers,
and he will actually share
a real customer example
that we're pretty excited about.
Lastly, Gian will join us
on the stage from ServiceNow
and he will do a demo.
It will do a walkthrough
of something exciting
that they're working on
about integrating AWS Health
and ServiceNow and he'll
finish up with a demo.
It's a silent session, so we
can't really take questions
on the stage.
Afterwards, happy to
meet with you downstairs
outside of the stage,
we actually have the AWS
Health product team here
that would help answer some
of the questions as well.
So let's get into it.
We're gonna use the term
lifecycle event a lot today,
so let's get on the same
page as what we mean by them.
Lifecycle events are schedule changes
that require coordination
and are part of our
continuous improvement in AWS.
The three common types of lifecycle events
are routine changes.
First, I think that's the one
that most of us are familiar with.
These are the changes that
their lifecycles are their,
sorry, the timelines are predictable,
are easily predictable.
So think of a EKS lifecycle
versions that are deprecating
and you need to upgrade to newer versions.
The timeline for that is 14 months,
so you can easily predict them.
Same thing for some of the
other services that we have.
But so another type is a less common type
of lifecycle events.
This is non-routine changes.
Think of hardware retirements that we do.
These timelines are not
really easily predictable.
We can anticipate them easily,
but we can't really
predict their timelines
until we get closer to when
we want to cycle out a piece
of hardware from our fleets.
Lastly, but definitely not least
are the urgent changes.
These are the types of changes
that we don't get the luxury
of plan ahead in advance.
Think of security patches that
we need to roll out globally
and we need to make sure that
they reach all the components that need
to be updated in a very quickly.
So we may get maybe a couple
of weeks of notice in advance.
So now that we've kind
of covered what are the
common types of lifecycle events, we need
to talk about why they're necessary.
So through these changes,
we are able to improve
the performance for our services
and keep improving the
performance of our services.
This is also how we enable
features, new features
and improve the security
posture of the infrastructure,
which is what we are responsible for
on our side on the AWS side.
Lastly, this is how we actually keep
the components of the cloud up to date
and make sure everything is
running on the latest versions,
both hardware and software.
But you need to know that
at any given time there are
thousands of changes
happening in the background,
but we try our best
to make sure these things
are happening seamlessly
and without the need for
customers to take action.
But there are always a subset
of changes that require
that are require customer action.
So today's session is gonna
be focused on those types
of changes, the changes
that require customer
action and coordination.
So let's look at one example
just to bring it all together.
EKS lifecycle, Amazon EKS
lifecycle starts really
with upstream open source.
When Kubernetes launch a new version,
they support it for about 12 months.
EKS then supports that
same version for 14 months.
So Kubernetes supported for 12 months.
EKS supports it for a couple more months,
so total of 14 months.
That period is called standard
support period for EKS.
Six months prior to reaching
that end of standard support,
that 14 months, EKS notifies
customers through AWS Health
and that six months is
ideally used by customers
to upgrade their clusters
and move off of that older version.
But for customers that
can't upgrade in time,
EKS will automatically roll them into
what we call extended support.
So extended support kicks in
at the end of that 14 months
for the clusters that remain
on that older version.
That gives you an extra 12
months on the extended support,
but it comes at a cost.
So during that, as long as
your clusters are running on
that extended support, you incur cost.
It does give you the flexibility,
but it also at over time, the
the cost of this will add up,
especially if you're running at scale.
At the end of that 12, extended 12 months.
So that now you have a
end-to-end 26 months of support.
At the end of that 26 month,
if you still have clusters
that are running on the old version,
EKS will automatically
upgrade your clusters.
Basically a force upgrade.
But all of these seem kind of
manageable if you're running,
your workloads are running
at a smallest scale.
Let's say you're a startup
or POC size, you're in that scale.
You have a couple of clusters.
You may have some RDS instances,
a few lambda functions.
It's pretty manageable.
You can pull up the console,
you can go look at the
changes that are coming up.
You can maybe even look
at rely on looking at
documentation every once in a while.
But as you get to the growth
stage where you're kind
of growing, you have now
some critical workloads,
you have customers that are
relying on their your uptime,
so it's not as easy to
bring workloads down to
for maintenance.
This is where most customers
start to feel the challenges
of managing life cycle.
Email is no longer as reliable.
Looking at the console constantly is not
as reliable anymore
because you may have
multiple teams, global teams,
you can't really reach
across the the office
and ask your teammate
to make sure to upgrade
this cluster or take action.
But when you get even
bigger to a larger size,
hopefully all your businesses
are growing at this pace
and you get to the enterprise level
where now you have even
more critical workloads,
maybe you're relying on
hundreds of different services
at AWS, then each of them
will have their own timelines
and things continue to
get more complicated.
Now, at the largest scale,
which some of us we deal with
customers that have reached this scale,
you're gonna have siloed
teams that complete kind
of don't communicate
with each other at all.
And you may actually acquire
another company that comes
with their own tech debt, with
their own backlog of changes
that have kind of been putting off
because they have competing priorities.
So now you have this large set
of backlogs across your organizations
because the number of
resources has grown, number
of teams have grown, the competing
priorities have increased
where you have to choose
between maybe launching a new
feature or meeting your
business objectives
or managing the lifecycle of your changes.
So at this stage, it's very critical
to get very intentional to use the tools
and technology in this case AWS Health
to gain the right level of
visibility into what's changing
and when, and to bring in the
awareness to the right owners
and stakeholders at the right time
and accelerate driving action towards kind
of shrinking these backlogs.
So Andrew will join us on the stage
and show us the real implementation
of some of the solutions
that we have helped customer
build around AWS Health.
And from there on Gian will
take over for the demo.
- Thank you.
There we go.
Hey, thanks, everybody
and thanks for seeing fear
and introducing the issue.
So this is a specific
area I work in a lot.
So again, my name's Andrew Riley.
I work extensively with
customers operating at scale
and trying to work
through lifecycle events.
And in particular I work
with them on solutions
using AWS Health to
help with that problem.
So before we go deep into the solutions,
are do people generally
familiar with AWS Health already
like Jovans? Okay.
Most people, most people have heard of it.
The particular thing I wanna
do first is lay some groundwork
about what AWS Health does
and in particular the
features of AWS Health
that are specifically
designed for lifecycle events
because that's what we're
using at scale with customers
to put into this work.
So to go through it really
quickly, what is AWS Health?
It's the platform on which all
of the AWS services
communicate to you about events
that might be impacting the performance
or availability of your resources on AWS.
So if you use EC2, S3, RDS, EKS,
the service teams are
looking to communicate to you
about issues going on
with your environment
and things you need to know about.
So we wanna keep you informed.
Health is this through different channels?
So I think everyone is most
familiar with first interacting
with health by receiving emails,
but the same information is also
provided through the WS Health dashboard
and through programmatic means.
So the AWS Health API
and Amazon EventBridge
and your default bus in your accounts.
And it's these programmatic
means that we really use
to drive change in your environments.
So what kind of information
does AWS Health communicate?
Health events fall into
three primary categories,
operational issues, count notifications,
schedule changes.
Operational issues.
These are unexpected
events in your environment
or unexpected events in AWS
and we want to communicate
to you about single instance
failures could be an EC2
instance or an EBS volume,
but these can actually range
up to control plane events
with the API for that
service that you're using.
So we wanna let you know what's going on
that AWS is addressing it
and help you make determinations about,
is this me or is this you?
Account notifications.
These are general events related
to the administration
security of your accounts.
So security issues, you
might be be very interested
to action them quickly, but
there are general events about
feature availability for
the services you use.
For instance, introducing
that there's another version
of an SDK available for
you without necessarily
deprecating the original version.
But schedule changes is
where I want to focus today
because schedule changes
are resource specific.
So meaning there's a specific
resource in your accounts
that you're using, like a database,
a cluster, some instance.
And there's a change coming
for it on the specific date
and we wanna make you aware of it.
Within schedule changes,
there's a subset specific
event type called planned
lifecycle events that were
introduced two years ago.
Planned lifecycle events
are specifically designed
for addressing the challenges
of making lifecycle event,
sorry, lifecycle event
management, frictionless at scale.
They're directly intended
to be used programmatically
and these factor heavily
into the solutions
that we talk about.
So the couple features we want
to talk specifically about are
these are things that
health built based on direct
feedback from you.
You wanted a better way
to pull Health event data
into tools that you use.
You receive email notifications,
but you're looking for a better way
to do this than parsing
that event message.
So we're also providing the information in
that event in structured
metadata that you can better use
to match into the payloads
for APIs you're gonna call.
Every event we're giving you the, sorry,
each of these events have
a resource specificity
and we're giving you these events
with the full Amazon resource name ARN of
the resources involved.
So to make it easy to
understand which account
these live in, which region,
what's the specific idea
of the resource in the service fund.
Along with resource specificity,
we're providing dynamic burndown.
So that means for each
resource you receive a status,
whether that is pending
your action or resolved,
and you can understand
how much work you've done,
how much is left to do
within your environment
and you wanna make these events fit
into your planning cycles.
So when do your teams normally work?
Can they balance their priorities
with delivering features
to your business with the
maintenance work that they need
to do to maintain their operations?
And along with those
timelines, you want to be able
to maintain visibility of these events
through their entire lifecycle.
So Farzin mentioned that
you're receiving notification
in advance from the services
you use about when these
lifecycle events are happening,
but for instance, for extended
support, you might have one,
two, or three years of
extended support occurring
after the change date.
And you wanna maintain
visibility of what the status
of those resources in your environment so
that you can continue to action them.
And to give you a lifecycle
of a planned lifecycle event,
this all starts with setting a date.
So for instance, RDS planned
lifecycle events for Aurora.
The service team gives you five years
of standard support from
the launch of that service.
So we know when the lifecycle events
going to occur into the future.
They begin planning
to send you a reminder about
this one year in advance.
So they begin working to get the list
of resources in your accounts
in scope for this change
and push them to the
Health Burndown service.
The burndown service is tracking whether
that resource is pending your
action or it's been resolved
and then it pushes
updates to your accounts.
And this process occurs daily.
So when you action a resource,
the generates a new list,
pushes it to burndown, you get an updated,
you get an updated list for
what's been resolved recently
and you can better act, you
can better tell the current
state of these resources
in your environments.
And this continues until the change date.
So on the change date,
this is when this particular change will
begin to affect your environment.
So whether that's an operational
upgrade that that you take
or if it's that extended
support is enabled
or it could be a security change.
If you remember the RDS
certificate rotation
that occurred last year, there's
different types of events
that are not specific to extended support
and there are things that
we need you to know about
and be able to handle on
a regular ongoing basis.
So how do you use planned lifecycle events
to improve the processes
and experience that you have
with these resources?
I like to frame this conversation with
the AWS Health maturity model.
The health team developed
the maturity model
to represent the different
stages that you go
through in your journey
towards health's vision
for a frictionless experience,
managing lifecycle events at scale.
So we all start with manual processes,
but we wanna build into
automations that allow you
to automatically ingest this
data to assign responsibility
for it and ultimately work
towards making it easier
for your teams to action these
events in the first place.
So let's start at the beginning.
So in the reactive stage,
you're receiving
information from AWS Health
through the health dashboard as emails.
If you've configured chat
channel notifications
through Slack or Microsoft Teams.
These are human readable
notifications, they're good
for point in time awareness.
And when you're in small environments,
this is a good way to keep informed.
So as these teams send you events,
you receive emails
and emails like this one.
So this one's telling you
about Aurora Postgres 13
end of standard support.
So is everybody getting
these emails? Yeah.
Are you receiving a lot of these emails?
Okay, so that is what
we're here to talk about.
It's moving away from emails
as the primary mechanism
for managing lifecycle events.
This email represents a
lot of information though,
and it's what service does is effect,
what's the version being deprecated,
what's the related change I need to do?
What date does this occur on?
And in specific, if this is
far into the future, you know,
how am I tracking when I
need to follow up on this?
Where can I find the list of affected
resources so I can start
working through it?
So in the small environments
that Farzin was mentioning,
you might have a small, small team
or even single developers within accounts
and you know all the resources
used by your applications.
So this is manageable.
But as you grow and you have more teams
and more resources under their
management, you need to start
to have processes to track these
and reduce the risk of
missing one of those emails.
Because, I think from the
nods I saw in the audience,
you get, there's a volume,
there's a challenge
with the volume of the number
of emails you're getting.
And you don't want to be in this position
where you've missed a critical change
for just the other volume
of messages you're getting.
So as you grow more teams, like I said,
now you might be in a
model where you have SREs
or central teams that are responsible
for tracking these events.
And while they don't own the resources,
they own responsibility for making sure
that your teams action
them on a regular basis
and before the change dates.
So they're still receiving
these human readable notifications.
But you want to start using
a programmatic approach.
And this is the first
thing that we focused on
with our large enterprise customers.
The scale of whom are using not just tens
or hundreds of accounts,
but thousands of accounts,
potentially hundreds of
thousands of resources
and need scalable mechanisms
to approach these.
So you're receiving events
and you want to use these
with your operational tools,
your ITSM tools, risk management tools,
but you need to do this
through a different channel than email.
So I just showed you the email
version of a health event,
but this is that same
event received as event
as an EventBridge message.
It's in JSON format.
The human readable message
still appears in this event,
but the content of this message
and the salient details are
pulled out into individual key
value pairs that you can
use with your tooling.
You can use them to form
the payload of a message
that you're gonna send
to the APIs of your tools
to create events in those,
to track these resources
and manage them, and manage
them much better scale.
So I wanna highlight a few things.
These events have many
common fields between
a standard health event and
a planned lifecycle event.
But the first thing I
want you to notice is
within scheduled changes
I talked about there being
this event type of
planned lifecycle events.
The first thing you need
to do is filter down
to just these events
because you're going to be taking these
into your operational tooling.
And we're not trying to
recreate the the scale
and volume issue you have with email.
A lot of people suffer
from notification fatigue.
The whole point of this
is to make things clear
to say central teams to
have a good visibility
of just the list of top level changes
and individual DevOps engineers to be able
to understand their
particular responsibilities.
And the first thing you're going to do
is understand there is a top
level change in this case
for Amazon Aurora Postgres
13 end of standard support.
And this is reflected across
all the health events you
receive across all the regions
and accounts that you use.
So you can understand
there's one top level change
with potentially many
resources associated to it.
This this event is
occurring in the future,
it's upcoming, it'll will
apply to your accounts
on the start date.
So in this case 28th of February, 2026,
extended support will
begin on your remaining
resources you haven't actioned.
So use this as the due date
for the change across your creating.
And like I mentioned,
resource specificity.
So in this case we're
providing you the resource ARNs
also the status and the update time.
So when we last noticed a change
with this moving from pending to resolved.
So, pardon me, we're gonna
share some links about,
share some links at the end
about solutions you can use
to actually just start
calling those APIs like
for common tools at the end
of this end of this session.
Alright, so using that health event,
you've called the API
for one of your tools.
You've recorded this as a change
and you're looping through
that list of resources
to create subtasks for that change.
So this provides you one top
level visibility of the list
of changes that are
affecting your environment.
But that can be a concise list.
You maintain per resource
visibility for the status of each
and the amount of work that's
needed in your environment.
So you still have a manual
action in this case though,
which is you need to assign those tasks,
the different teams in your environment.
You have reduced the
risk of missing an event
and you've reduced the
amount of work you need
to report on these in your environment
because you're
automatically ingesting this
information, the tools you use.
So you don't have a different dashboard
or different tool you have to
use to manage these things.
But as you're growing again right
now you're tracking these changes
and as you grow further it
becomes necessary address
that second part that I talked about,
which is per resource
ownership and accountability.
So in the secondary, pardon me,
in the second area, you
wanna pull in information,
excuse me, you wanna
pull in information about
who owns these resources and
who can take action on them
and begin the automatic
assignment of those, pardon me,
of those change tasks to those
teams to allow 'em to action.
So my experience here
the last year working
with customers is that
everyone has different
metadata they're pulling in
from their own environments.
A lot of you'll have a
change management database
that's kind of give you a good
view of your organization.
It might be down to per
resource specificity.
But even if you don't
track things as granularly,
as individual resources, most often
one account will have specific contacts
or you'll have specific
contacts for an application.
And maybe that ties back
to financial ownership cost centers.
You also see many
customers put standardized
tagging practices in place.
So there's usually a wealth of information
about a specific resource
that you can get just from
looking at those tags.
And again, we'll have some
samples later about pulling in
that tag information into these processes.
But this is an easy way to identify
and link these things to
their respective owners.
Alright, so now you know who's responsible
for these resources, you're able
to automatically assign them
and get the right people,
right people or teams,
the visibility that you have,
but to their specific resources only.
So you're reducing the
noise that they experience
and keeping things focused on
just what they need to action
and giving them ample
warning in advance allows 'em
to fit these things into their planning
normal flow of work
avoids urgent interrupts
and the operational impacts
that can occur if they miss these events.
And really this is where
we see the resolution rate
for customers employee solutions
is take a hockey stick turn
so they get a better experience
working through these events.
You see them action these events earlier
and faster and you see
a return in investment
for the time you put in to
implement a solution like this.
So I mentioned in our
most mature environment,
what we're really trying
to do is make it easier
for those teams to action
the events in the first place
action their particular resources.
So we see teams building
workflows off of these systems.
So for instance, you might
have standard deployment
practices in your environment.
You want to automatically bring those in
and give teams directions
about what they need
to do to action that event.
You probably all use
infrastructure's code to a degree
to a large degree.
So you might actually be
suggesting a poll request
to that team just directly against
one of their repositories.
That immediately lets them
understand here's the change
that needs to be made and
start integration testing.
We also see teams take
steps with gen AI triage.
So they're not just ingesting these events
and assign that teams, but
they're also deciding the
priority in which they need
to be actioned based on other
criteria within their environments.
Like are these tier zero
applications for you?
Do you have other priorities
for those teams based on
cycles you already know.
So all of this is to
make it easier for you
to action these events you just assigned.
And with an aspirational
goal of fully automating
this process, the governance, excuse me,
governance policies happening
automatically at the same time.
I want to give you a a
concrete example of what one
of our customers that we've
worked with has done this year.
So the BMW group, they're
headquartered in Munich, Germany.
They have 159,000 employees
across 30 facilities in
15 different countries.
They manage 10,000 AWS accounts
and these support the
premium digital services
and their connected fleet of automobiles
of 23 million automobiles worldwide.
And they share similar goals to you.
So they wanna maintain
visibility of their environment,
they want to automate processes,
but in their words,
the technical lifecycle
management team at BMW, they want
to distill what gets pushed
down to their organization.
They want to delegate
responsibility for the resources
and scope to specific SREs
and give them the
flexibility with guardrails
to do these things on
their own timetables.
And most importantly, TLM wants to do this
by keeping noise as low as
possible for as long as possible
and avoid over escalating to these teams
and causing kind of churn for them.
So this is a complete architecture
for health in their environment.
It's not just planned lifecycle events.
I wanna walk you through specific
sections demonstrating the
ingestion, the automated
assignment that we talked about.
So it all starts with a process
to pull the health API on a daily basis
and pull in new events and
updates to existing events.
They take that data just like
I showed you in the example,
feed it into an S3 bucket
and begin to power
processes based on that.
So they're taking a step with AWS glue
to merge data from their cloud data hub.
That's the mapping of the
resources to the teams
that own them and where they
live in their environment.
They'll take a process to
then put a Jira issue onto the
boards for those teams
and link them with an overarching legend.
So that's their link from the level change
to the individual actions
required by teams.
And you're thinking about the,
let's say the six month life,
six month notice in the lifecycle here.
They're allowing those teams
to work through these within
that period until they
have some guardrails.
So they're also using the same data
to power BI reporting.
So they've provided QuickSight dashboards
that have role level
security, meaning that myself
as an engineer, I only
see the resources in scope
for my team, nobody else's.
The TLM team also uses
that as a fail safe.
So within that period of say six months,
if those teams haven't actioned
the items with four weeks
to go in one of these
events, they begin escalating
to them through ServiceNow.
This process results in a
significantly improved experience
for their teams.
I actually do want to
call out here that again,
there's more things on this slide
than just plain lifecycle events.
They're also interested
in those issue category
events I talked about earlier.
So it means the ongoing things
or near real time events
they might be receiving
and they want to avoid delays from
the once a day polling they're
doing for the health API.
So integrating with EventBridge,
they get push notifications
of these events and they can use these
to drive automated workflows,
make their teams aware
of operational issues
with ServiceNow as well.
So BMW wants these flows routing to work
as seamlessly as possible.
And based directly on their feedback
and the feedback from similar customers,
we've launched AWS health
labels just this past week.
So this is available
for all customers now,
but you can filter health events
based on whether they are,
whether label is actionable,
whether based on their persona,
route them to the right
recipients for your organization
for operations, security and billing.
So if you were looking at the schema
or the example event I sent
earlier, right at the bottom,
the new metadata already
appears on those events
and for plain lifecycle events,
those are marked action required
and with your operations
team as the persona.
But I wanna get back to what BMW
achieves with their architecture.
So first, by building plane
lifecycle event management into
their processes and planning
this architecture enables
the BMW team to perform most
of their upgrades on
meaning in the last several
months, they've shrunk the portion
of their resources on
extended support to only 4%
of their RDS and 2% of their EKS fleets
resulting in a significant cost savings.
They've reduced the operational
issues from missed events.
So where the developer wasn't
aware, they took an upgrade,
they weren't expecting and
they've improved developer
satisfaction with a system
that respects their autonomy
but also holds them accountable.
And in all this while
reducing the overhead
for the technical lifecycle
management team by 90%.
So I've shown you a lot
and if you're thinking this is great,
but my team doesn't have the resources
or time to implement this right now,
I want to ask you to
strongly reconsider that.
The teams that we work
with spend about two weeks
of a developer's time getting familiar
with the pattern that they need to deploy
and getting a foundational
architecture out there that
immediately gives them a benefit.
So one catches the events that you,
it didn't necessarily have awareness of.
You might know that that EKS
or RDS cadence is occurring,
but those off cycle events
are things that are unique.
You capture those as well
and directly if you are already
paying for extended support,
this investment pays you back.
So if you're thinking you don't have time
to make this happen,
this is where I'd like
to turn the mic over to Gian
to talk about how ServiceNow
is working to enable the vision
of effortless lifecycle management scale.
- Awesome, thank you, Andrew.
You can take that actually, I'll use mine.
So here we go.
We are at the final part
of this presentation.
You're very likely getting ready
to celebrate a little bit
more with the upcoming parties
and all partner events,
but this is gonna be, it might be
the most important session
from a point of view
of connecting everything
that we said about the great innovations
for AWS Health into your
existing businesses.
So how do we take all the
technical parts innovations
that we have seen
and we get them to have
a bigger context on
how they impact the business?
There are a few things that
I would like to mention
and I'm gonna switch screens right now.
First things first, please do acknowledge
that we have a safe harbor
Notice today we're gonna
actually, as a matter of fact,
announce a new collaboration
with AWS and this is a new integration.
You're the very first customers
to learn about this integration.
And before we go
and see a little bit more about it,
who has ever heard of ServiceNow?
I wanna see a few hands up there, right?
And who is currently actively
using ServiceNow? Awesome.
Good few of you. Who wants
to go to the parties?
No, I'm kidding.
So ServiceNow is as a matter
of fact, a unique platform
because it's, you can think
about it as the control tower
of your AI and software.
As a matter of fact, you
can see that we integrate
with any cloud, not only AWS,
although we know that especially
when this event is your
favorite cloud, isn't it?
We also integrate with all of your systems
'cause we wanna make sure
that you know exactly
what is your IT estate looking
like at any point in time
and we merge all this data
with your business level
of data, which means
how do you then associate
each single resource
to your business applications
to your business processes.
Now this is just to give a
little bit more context on why
ServiceNow is relevant.
Because to Andrews
and Farzin point,
customers are willing now
to have huge deployments
of AWS and beyond at scale.
And we have seen that
there are different ways
in which you could already as of today
integrate your AWS Health with ServiceNow
and essentially get the
value of the platform,
which is just one thing.
If there's one thing you
need to remember out of
today's session is the context
that ServiceNow gives you.
Not only about AWS and your deployment,
but about every single IT
deployment that you currently have.
This is just the as-is status.
And we've been talking to
many customers such as BMW
that really want to have, they want
to capture these lifecycle
events at scale so
that they can have broader
context on top of them
and they can manage
them a little bit better
with change management
and with business context.
The use cases are the usual ones, the ones
that we have heard from BMW
as an example, which means
how do you get to establish
concrete ownership
or even a business cost
center that is associated
with your impacted resource
or even operational issues.
We have cost optimization
or even more simply I
would say cloud governance.
Cloud governance is definitely one
of the biggest use cases here.
Now these are some of the
reasons why customers are already
doing this manual
integrations with ServiceNow.
But this is not only it.
As a matter of fact, we are
very happy to introduce you
to one of the newest innovations
we're planning to introduce
as of next year.
And we've been working really
hard with AWS to listen to all
of you and all of our
customers that have been asking
for an out-of-the-box integration,
which is the new AWS Health
and ServiceNow integration.
This is the paramount step
because we are partnering in
order to essentially allow you
to ingest those events,
those lifecycle events,
specifically the scheduled changes
and the account notifications
into the ServiceNow platform
directly, automatically.
Which means for each one of those changes,
you'll automatically get
the blast radius impact
and you'll be able to see
not only for each account,
but also how many resources are impacted,
how many application
services are impacted,
and eventually how many business
applications are impacted.
You'll get all of that plus
proactive notifications to
who really needs to take
care of those changes.
And don't worry if this
doesn't look as clear yet
'cause I'm gonna show you a demo.
Now, another part that you need
to keep in mind is ServiceNow
we've always partnered with
customers that are deploying
this technology at scale.
So you're deploying essentially
zero touch changes at scale.
And I'm now gonna switch screens
so I can show you a demo.
So let's imagine that
for a moment we are still
in the AWS Health dashboard.
Who is familiar with this
dashboard, by the way,
the AWS Health Dashboard, right?
This is just your regular interface
where you can clearly see
all the upcoming changes
or I would say lifecycle events.
You can see all the different categories
and information about each one of them.
Let's say that we focus on one
of the Lambda Planned
lifecycle events here
at the very bottom.
Of course you'll get all the details
that Andrew was showing you
earlier on, on the context
from an AWS point of
view on the ownership of
that Lambda function, et cetera.
But let's say that you want
to get more, you want to know
how many application services
are gonna be impacted.
How is my business
potentially been impacted
by this upcoming change?
And how do you automate
your change requests
and change tasks?
So you effectively do not
need to manually create them.
And that is exactly why we
already have, by the way,
a product that is very useful for all
of your cloud governance use cases.
Not only the events lifecycle use cases,
which is cloud workspace.
This is a one single pane of glass
where you can see everything
about your cloud resources the
way that they are divided
between on-prem and in the cloud.
And also you can see just
everything that you need
to care about your cloud
deployments, such as
a clear breakdown of all
of your cloud accounts,
but not only with the
traditional details about costs,
about ownership,
but multiple levels of
ownership, multiple associations
to your business, let's say cost center
or business applications
and service mapping,
which means you know exactly
how each account is related
to each other part of your business.
Now let's say that we want to dig deeper
and we are impersonating, in
this case a specific owner
of the Center of Excellence,
of the Cloud Center of Excellence.
Let's say that you want to
know a little bit more about
everything else that is happening
to your specific environments.
This integration that we
are just announcing will
essentially connect to
your AWS Health dashboard
and essentially capture
all the different upcoming
notifications and schedule changes
and bring them into ServiceNow
so you know exactly what's happening
to the different cloud
environments that you are managing.
And you'll get also a clear breakdown of
how these changes are
effectively impacting your
different resources.
Specifically you can see here
you'll also see a breakdown
of the different resources
that are primarily impacted by them.
And you can of course
dig a little bit deeper
inside each one of these
categories, such as of course,
the Lambda function.
And in this case you'll see that
that very same lambda
function, planned change
or planned lifecycle event
is effectively already captured in here.
Now of course, ServiceNow is
not only gonna have the context
that is already coming from
AWS, it will offer you more.
As a matter of fact, you'll
have all the different affected
accounts that are being
brought to ServiceNow
with the ServiceNow context.
You'll have ownership of
whoever needs to act on this
because you already have
an automated change request
that is being being created
as being already created for you.
Now the change request contains
all the different details
that you need to care about.
Specifically we can see that
there is already someone
that has been assigned
to that change request
so that they can act on it.
You have a different priority information,
you have the service context
so you know exactly which
of your services could be impacted by it
and more specifically all the
different details have also
been pulled directly AWS into this change.
You'll also see all the
different resources impacted by
that very same change
beyond that Lambda function,
as I said, the services that
will be impacted by them.
And most importantly,
you'll have all these
different change tasks
that will be created
for each single account
that is impacted by it.
So you don't need to do any
manual tasks any longer.
Everything is already pre-made for you.
Now the cloud leader will want to know
how these change tasks are processed
and you'll be able to decide
who needs to act on them,
who's the owner, but not
only a single specific user,
but rather also a bigger user group
that will be assigned to them.
And they will of course
get all the details
that we already talked about
and also about the effective
CIs record, record history,
but more importantly, this is the view
that you need to keep in mind.
This is where everything
that we talked about comes together,
where all your technology infrastructure
is being connected meaningfully to see
how each single component is
effectively impacting your
services and beyond your
business applications.
Which means you're finally
identifying the bridge
between your ideal world,
where you have your business
enterprise architecture designs
and your real as-is it infrastructure.
Now, that was a quick demo for you,
but I will kindly ask you if
you are interested to know more
and specifically to partner with us
to work on these innovations,
please do scan the QR code.
We're absolutely very happy
to collaborate with you
and if you want to stop
over just for a few seconds
after this presentation, we'll stay here
so we can get any of your questions.
And that was my part, so
I'm gonna hand it back over
to you folks.
- Yeah, thanks, everyone.
So we are going to take
some questions off the stage
if any questions, if you
have any questions for us.
But for 2026 AWS Health's vision is
to continue focus on improving
or enhancing the ways you can
integrate with your tools,
bring in some AI features
in the next year,
but also we have some
ready to use solutions
that, yeah, you can, if
you follow this link,
it will take you to a place
where you can actually access
some ready to use solutions.
So I encourage you to take
some time and captured this,
but we will also have a booth at the AWS
in the expo support.
I don't see anyone taking
any screens anymore,
so I'm gonna move on to this.
So meet us at the AWS
support booth at the expo.
Here's how you can find us there.
And here's also some
other support products
and you can take you to the
other features of AWS support.
With that, thanks, everyone,
and I hope you enjoy
the rest of re:Invent.
- [Andrew] Yeah, thanks.
- [Gian] Awesome, thanks, all.